Identification this is the interview redress.
With a with the stand,
London boilermaker in Newcastle on the twenty fourth of February nineteen eighty two he was very along the are only two
years later, Wembley at the thirty women will make you when I speak of it as a direct by seven you were anyway, veggie,
it's a long while she was no longer of the Earth twelve months after I feed the premiership of official who is the
youngest boilermaker read by about eighteen months one of fellow came in the working mate of mine your previously going
to the bar.
I made several that sounds a bit of living in a matter of time to get a job that Mister Hippel,
he was outside the manager of the film on your down to occasion
but eventually said well that you are the assist those that will give you the no of the
or fever here young man alive heading on the other, realising that both of them are a really good
and I started over twenty who started straight away on the artist, it is that they were about
and the view started as a riveting where your plate at the assembly so you are building up in actual fact for the
relative the very secular regular place they move a particular many expected and the need section,
plus together some of the life they were about eighty ability to imagine.
The early staggering up the other order in Jamaica varied according to think of the section are all the lateral racing
well they got down to the other very rarely read that you are in those days sermon.
It was all riveting wasn't that map can you explain the process as you remember it over the assembly of the of the
arched her the rigours job and your job afterwards, however,
have a yet all actually the job was assembled in the shop may shop and the first stand a fully assembled in the shop
and before that came out the next spammers may
and fitted to the first the so as to make sure that the be no different when
when the last so long with respect to the shop will not hold rare agreement out to make sure that everything perfect
that you have no trouble with the
and naturally they have been turned up driving fit into the whole police prisons make sure that free go to the bulk
within that in the effort whatever.
but In many cases the slight distortion was the plague put a bowl and every time you could be placed together,
but sometimes be sixty four the sixteenth of them so for the level of the river came along he have to come along the
river, then an as you know it expands vinegar beyond critical point rivet amazingly well in reverse
when you put them in the river,
not the River about contracts will contraction naturally placed together well in a utterly are seen.
Possibly dozens of rivers within them. We have cut them out so that the place of Fuller together, then the river.
We go through the inspectors would come along test each ribbon individually
and possibly level hundreds in one US dollar, so there is a lot of work done as you learned
and happily Lilly government wasted away because they were that particular about making joints,
extra time F will only a very well at question here is so in the first place you'd have to put in pens as well is as
bold, what do I want proportion was pens involves well.
Her regular whether they will love these pins, according to the number of plates
and pillion have that sometimes be legible, not another Gay survey my vanity.
Six of them long member just a slight taper either in of state was in the quarter steel pin were okay.
Well the regular human supplement, as we prepayment healthily signal a selection are they dislike them
and get them in the rigours
and then he can for the boilermaker Venables his job to come up with the bulk were people of the world well then been
spectrum come along, as they will joints of the plate is not close enough.
He had affiliated insert in the whole
and have a little foot well if he could insert which possibly measure of sale of each,
I can't say you're the one that have to be put in a minimally mother with the place at the Vegemite,
beautiful thing that the big birthday before they were allowed to river. The job of if you've got your site.
Hence, as I stated earlier, the root of the river theme
and contractor must take place in sprawling replaced together which you couldn't do by bolting daily with
but above that every element of the case.
If they collided practically every joint at the but are definitely a job whereby every joint to be so five.
The lymph node- version of DragonDictate length later on in the sea here
or less of a particular about both your big plaything tight
and it was Boilermakers job to type permanent repaint your job the ones that were bolting up first before the rivers to
get into fight we could get the river would come along expect would check the first equated with them along right with
the reports in them as a writer
and that we cut them out now are sometimes the River about the Lib Dems have you it behind someone
or wipe with another in the boilermaker cross cut through the centre in there was never any Oxley by the way of the
cutting down on your some reason it was always done by putting a crosscut back the record of that which is thereby
river up in the battered the rounded and giving evidence eighty thousand litres of bacteria.
The back is one half of the nine plus eight in other words,
was bowled well back up a fairly good measure of the one after that it plus one eight.
The diameter of the bat will you put across that and then when you write down the plate when you
and several of them are made.
That we did with the head of the month was surely affect well that you have punched that river,
there believe me though, heart,
both of them without much weight on the section the Giffnock who holds to have time to they have to be drilled at their
own way of getting them out punch failed yes, I understand to me when you are home together,
doing everything afterwards or we will have whole time I was a seminal essence is a different sort of job,
although the river discovered,
finally responsible for that though for the joint is no know actually the boilermakers responsible for the quality of
its lengthy finish building up the sake he is back to say okay
and that it what you have found the length of five will get labour.
It would stand member that of a long outside because of the work went on inside the pool really bothered with in the
examiner way down. You can often than that in the terrific pressure dealers as they avoid all the plates together.
Therefore, the river.
The job
and then up the side that figure one million comeback to mencap one out because we live willing to fifty seventy get-together
tool might be a price of market make sure you do that without no way otherwise of the flower go about your within the
snap will have a map because of lust are well with that through the other room will need to decide that rip them if
they have so people are sitting became lead to eleven in the day that they have become out you the five sure that the
valley, well if of the thumb gave the still a very heavy wind is a pleasure to have put treasures.
It is very leisurely evidence that they above record every top choice, and as and when outside of the plates,
then the tenth of life.
They have the bed with reducing down the line acre want down the base of the about half some could have been a little
bigger than those of the start of the gradual vision, a half people are beginning
and they gradually be reduced out of the wood of the given that the incidentally VM, the amount of thumb,
the accuracy that was required arm was required was it not because of everything is straight in at that they had to get
the egg. The angles exact type is exact in order to meet in the centre.
I have well either side of the bridge were up there that I will take applicable in both their them there was a slap of
concretely high with the surveyor at least.
I stand
and that the wonderful in my mind that are among because they were that all particular because the bridge that of the
start of the little without the line in the Simon got to the centre might be at about the selection of staff from about
the bottom of the lovely so here is the lead with your monthly limit is there about three steel ropes are the rows
and rows of these able take a backup taken into the sure rock on she will as well.
I think they achieve level was the only bridge of the way I have been
and gone among the seventy dollars a year than Barlow began more were to be sophisticated because eleven I realise were
pleased them family has researched the Wellington mail information that they could anchor the steel raved about the
support of the way of the actual amount, plus the creeper crane which weighed approximately five hundred and four.
That was creeping up after each,
then went up creep up like a bicycle chain will be heavily with only very slowly on the bridge that vibrate a little
humour well over the working of the outsider that considered the feeling of cluster B really feeling this movement take
place the new. The claimant going up the news that the first of Monday the greater the risk.
Please will be out of the rough laws in their home in my mind at the way of the fitting of a blow around during our
move around
when the weather was while yet to make the it was even though they does love the did not earn homogeneous picture drawn
with the three. One five an hour. Just big your sharp game though that, and so the now lives on a very hot day.
I have them twelve measures will so that none of these rivets on the value issue workload in the that of the work that
a centralised that being rated almost together, but was locked.
This year the rivers eventually and therefore the latter part of his life.
Even the hang of, and from the record one good support the rabbi level thereon so that have well the sheer
and the methane is hanged out see that people
and workplace factors that down the hang of them at the effect island with the King of May.
I
when I look back the amount of the delivery lies in the what one of linear theirs that the number of because they make my
impact them have a feeling they are actually hear the test
but with the way that they have elected them in the amount of the full away from the ground that the average of the
like have no I believe they weren't that they were built like that the children colours propped up from a made the
great one that both of the five will be the below her the several bridges were built like that a lot more in Zimbabwe.
In addition to these several bridges were built like that in Zimbabwe in Rhodesia by father but not the same.
That know any of a size that the big has the fifth of them have been completely for the limbo with excellent
but will come later.
I have one thing in the me the way that gay and lonely
when have the slow down the plaintiff you don't forget that in the lead in Sydney. Those rows of map on the Capel.
The case went back to me about the men have a meet the low weight these heavy threes diameter steel rope that
expenditure which is never in hundred feet stretch.
I should say that that was the so that at the very least one row below the upgrade below have faith that do the work
list of the top row on following that so therefore venture that take place.
The grapes were guaranteed to stretch twelve inches every hundred of our is a fact because I check them by asking one
of the engineers was amazing to think a rate they region diameter stretch made in the great weight stresses placed on
the the growth in the US.
They will have to spread because the bringing down the wood of the round the favour of the people alone to meet the
other.
They came up November come the mode of being out to make college with that you might be must deal with five hundred
pounds on the side of the liver level of therefore at the end of what has become about a third of men
and just the ladder down because of the ten inches square
and was hoping to the other one in the seventy at home in the pilot
and around the second what the defect images where will it was the pilot
and the term that was in the middle square pin was sure they jacked out ahead of the of the art show them to make sure
they would line up,
they are big round of levellers around pen with a one-to-one across the crossed out that a unified will then as I said
earlier at the square billing nervous weapons went out like like a finger-pointing are just had to get it in line
without a socket square socket square pin jacked them out ahead,
just to make sure they were absolutely aligned Holden that was apart from the the domain pens which came across the
accords that is to join in the three in charge in the first place in the letter they were only used it
when writing the middle to the square hole in one of the two there were no with a near the bottom,
there was only to one in the lower lower court of each one of that I wasn't your narrowminded that you are they where I
have pictures night will give that they are nevertheless the check them out to make a last bacon run transversely
crossover your life it with your getting a bar could have been things like memory pictures of the earlier posting me
the original calculation Troy I will use the value of the middle
and the such things I were to ask you about the conditions that the working conditions as those what was it like inside
the courtroom are welded gives that was developed because you knew that was going to be hard work
and the white space really that the earth will receive your man back within the industrial trouble we had a a few were:
a lunchtime meeting them will never after an output of the common move that that examine meeting are we never had any
industrial travel will be given to both of those like on the bridge unit, the and the when we applied more money.
After several spam are delegate jolly guys to the management to go to go to the happy,
but surely the no one ever got astray. We went them.
We got good money admittedly and because willing to got three thousand legal in Plymouth,
England are the figure for the budget for the Wellington bound pigment in them then that the thumb of Doctor T.
Wright, the allocated to think of it
when you take a supplement gave treated by a rectangle based posted by angled ballgown one seven eight four rate view
of the level of the well legal amount ablated over the later he will so was Kelly that will offsetting of rail twenty
seventeen.
I then my plans to them around the middle of a month of Blackburn Road, the rate may give the live close on the.
This will be little pain even when they leave a safe,
although the nation later we will now bring up any year the swivel cranes,
even though you have pictures of the scene of the guest rampages of them will the flood with having a the robust.
The jump of the others of:
the well of my money went twelve edge of the GMC went to well in either inevitable move more in the delegates of the
run-time well made himself a delay if I happily just like that of your made example
or unforgivable one going on with palpable favour among the many in the contract in the happy thing is up
and down that the biggest funeral Belinda and what are what about term on the outside of the court,
was it slippery in the morning years because you're a rough faith, just about you in the Elizabeth David,
but I have never found any year later, you love one that someone make them easier member mostly sent you today.
He will, I have invited them to go on coming up in the good one and one big way, the effect might later several
and that we will be pictured there were some leaning over his insight is to give above the adjustment of the washer
mother will become out of five banner down the bottom of the top with a member with full right down the vegetable,
" what we are a leader victim but he, as for the weight of the letter of your labour.
The member equally founded on a run in the taken of the purchase must simply fan of the spectators coming up the other
side of the human
and needlessly allowed to benefit them in my role will have a map way that you hear the order now after earlier to you
from imminent new mines are now the film hire telehealth he headed the brother of the best to have the Netherlands.
I think that Sir, he can you got in her abilities.
Both women in previous seasons download the welly of the work of the iMac number that the youngest of them.
We got them dropping at the club that the little basal last Bayesian before the clinicians up the plates are the bottom
port,
but in still open across the book of that display the whole of the subject of the rate who though they are greater than
the limit of the pin you believe you will in yesterday.
He took place well adjusted some of the plate winner down the window today that really scuttling the time of movement
different.
Either they could both of field scaffolding may make a film of the level of the method with the work done in excess of
the acting at arm level eleven, the golden Cambridge they had done a safety nets underneath.
I understand they were you several times.
Another bridges as well that he is in a safe and had somehow arrested that line matter-of-fact value,
but they did they have the great team now the big flavour like in the fairies with social workers cleanup so far.
Well the version to come aside so that on-site again over the key will that was over mistake.
I will now not several occasions of all of the possibly some baking bowls of tidying up on the block above all from the
back of the very value development in the associate him to give a freephone very because I remember reading about going
out with statement you grow up in that really happen is you are the better available at my college will stop people
something very by the be broken by the roof because they battered most than the government through monthly predicted
that only three plates though you imagine what it above the bakery length of everything is due member firm,
someone else of follow-up with with less effect than the BMA apprentice in the Kelly MMM falling human
and electronic sure you are.
He stepped off the vacant on the scaffolding that the division of the three place of the energy required
and that the different liable at the rate it will be fully gradually gut a walk along to get said the government
bedroom down in and the thirty when he was a little killing of the big Mt Lawley little fellow, Mister I.
View they say forget of shop. Q. Your stuffing manicured image that they are without the that the earth.
You either love in that hour shift.
These give a good Lilly bent over back missed the road is the cleaner and,
but luckily he backed audibly feeder of its only broke free red phone number correctly treatment.
Below are the back of your death.
The envelope ago
and more in most of the guys are made what Renison posts nip Renison was held at the botany synthesis
and it was Sydney at a senior livelihood will be bathrobe" either take back now by the wording of the letter that
extremely we are getting have a lot of friends twenty registered by the debate of eighteen -month-old me with me in the
money that the in and get a job even Scott from Kilmarnock
and apparently they toppled because of Lalonde Scott firm will probably it is in the heat had a job rather uni days of
the bingo to go the river.
They were badly that although I do like at all of the hospital at the boilermaker of the December were better than the
the method of your move,
especially inside that angle over eleven of the baccarat some of the these were the ninety best pressures.
These are living in June by the on the took of strongly held the level of the pro- EU management.
They never further than you ever support groups over who will let Anglo vascular coming on being a month, sixty,
sixty one inch angle on all the thickness of placement coming in them that would have to have someone because you
couldn't hold when you rooted leakage of leg against the nail holes are applicable at there have a couple of goodwill,
the river through cooked the mother was outside and that whatever steel tube
but in an they have in the compress them the river.
The cooker, but it should would go with a four twenty three thousand where they are local religions are present.
Well the apartment at this obstacle held with Natalie the product is easier to not down a lot will run contract to take
place at the regular
but I will see what a thing that goes up to a value early about using a together with the way they tell me
when they were riveting on the courts are upside down.
They used to go really is to go inside the court then another hold-up outside a one hundred quickly the system will
make the labour it have a Mayor Dolly 's he was all it is only used safely in the roof space down the bottom corner of
the pipe.
The point of the steel spoken to both the but the revision of the dial out just in the air on the user that a court,
the legal and exert a key
and did not doubt whether the blackout available without about the yes I have a level of the point I'm making is this
that therefore the the cover plate that was right down the centre of the upper and lower courts,
the displaced them together.
Yes you,
but must bend riveted upside down for the reporters on the bottom OIC of your get you where it was possible the river
always worked down the so what yes that was the fact that well-known}
third are allowed to get we get the move will the river as they gain sit down the lives of work that you are very led a
is holding me the rivet gun against his need and will revert the average had a grid.
The rigour which is heavily on whatever they thought one as well some big member of the government had to wait so
they'll won't work properly. They get older they go it them the year.
Labour would have his dolly working of something above this edit possible if not inevitable lunch after the heavy
weight ( the heat of the many disfavour with victory had been might be seven eight feet long, well the whole,
the Riverside, one of the enough about them to be found himself that most cases they used an adult return
and answer the two
and a lack of plunger inside of the band of well that if I another was being knocked from evenly only the head was
existing for the book on the boilermaker using graph of make the head on the sale of the family in
when they you have carefully some cases,
just because you have mentioned will bottles of her room well available that do not doubt trivia debating what you
think of her. when You are doing over to be developed in the way they will cease to make silo in my case mail.
I didn't move will not dispute among them below the line of learning to drive the mat is always on the side of the
river by the way.
In other words,
the river takes the world of because it might derivative them with above litter over Buckley back gives over the bulk
that in them that well naturally through the fact that they voted the receipt that they can take that out them in the
last the number who without letting go back,
before the make sure that you could rally snap around in there to make tighter case that last following getting
contractions safe place on every rivet will you get a one hour knockabout okay and if they did not doubt he,
taking eleven go back and one previous month.
Few that might willingly got back all the way along the seven zones like hard work. I worked out.
Nevertheless, two hundred
and eight lines of rivets across the harbour on the courts alone just above all the places in the lead all the joints
and such like two hundred
and eight Lions are rivets in the cord to learn from one side of the harbour to the other two hundred may driven two
hundred and eight lines of rivets from one side of arbiter. The other across the cords alone.
That's right across the harbour lengthwise on all public commitment because they sleep demonstrated.
You may longitudinally go across that way, run across the effluent give me a call.
There are two hundred and eight lines of rivets across the harbour,
but has worked it out to give some people some idea only rivers.
There are holding in the business of five to six million. In SOA was five million.
In summary,
lovers of six million mixed up with the lecture urges on the grave in the room that yes it with either five
or six million nine it suffered people say five million but to limit furnace.
The directorate on long nova hundred one hundred and one thousand cut out according to the Public Works,
you never like your average life that at the beginning of an early commitment to find out the date they will have made
the know them Avenue Hamley meant limits their work.
They were weighed only seminar how many tonnes they were evident,
however it now little different sizes senility actually know they calculated the first estimate was just over five
million
and the last estimate was round about six million of the set six million net bulge in the family go vegan of the havoc
that will they live in it outside of the two hundred one LaMonica well the Wakeman firm who weighed the missing they
weighed three thousand two hundred tonnes of rivers that they don't know what sizes were
or all of them 's analogy is actually calculated how many rivers.
There were at the very worst from five million six and it in the way of section of the court whether yes,
but I have it with me that altogether was about fifty eight thousand fifty two thousand tonnes,
it will you would have a core
but the BH is a half arches before their match with just under twenty thousand tonnes of death,
but nineteen thousand something each side of the harbour on a hundred and twenty five movement
but I was a eleven hundred and twenty eight cables on each side.
There was a hundred twenty eight, and each of them was supposed to carry one hundred and eight tonnes,
but at times wet as you said that stretch more than one.
Sometimes they carried up to about a hundred and twenty tonnes, but they were tested to three hundred
and sixty two there are about the one listed on a special machine in Middlesbrough
and even though a specially built for the job or at least limited to the three hundred and sixty to